do
[Music]
do
[Music]
hello everyone
yes sidnator it is going to be animal
crossing um
so i've had a very long week a very
stressful week
and i didn't want to play alan wake
i didn't want to play anything scary or
stressful so i thought today
i'm gonna play animal crossing because
i've been getting back into it again
recently
i'll explain why in a second
um
and
i thought i'd show you
what i've been working on in my spare
time
so
[Music]
so yeah i
last year i stopped playing animal
crossing before halloween
and now obviously it's halloween
jeez it's loud
it's halloween season and i'm like
i want to get all the cool halloween
gear so
i've been playing it again
i need to go to the shop every day
because i want to get sweets my animal
crossing is still so rudimentary it's
like embarrassing compared to like all
the other people's another thing but
i like it i'm still not at five stars
but
it's fine
but i thought we'll do this until about
10 or whatever
let's don't get changed so i don't
really like what i'm wearing now
happy thursday nelson
hi young man nothing here hey man
hey kevin
hey if 196
hey clay we're playing fatal frame on
the halloween stream which is the third
year so this room hasn't really changed
from when you saw it last i think you
saw it last i don't know if you did i've
added a few extra bits and bobs spot the
difference
uh let's go change our clothes
[Music]
oh it's good to see you too nelson
uh okay so let's let's change our hair
first of all because i only have my hair
up because i was wearing
wings the other day
i was wearing wings and a duck outfit it
was
it was the height of fashion um but
we're not gonna do that now
let's have this one
the pairing does ruin everything i think
that's why i used to love the old um
animal crossing game and then i kind of
stopped playing this quite early and i
honestly think the main thing is
comparison it's just i could see my
friends islands i could see people on
the internet's island and i was like
mine is so crap but when i played it
before it wasn't it wasn't even about
that it was just about you know enjoying
your own island
uh where is my witch's hat
let's be down here
[Music]
aha there it is should we wear a black
one
i did wear a red one with this before
but let's keep it simple let's wear a
black one
[Music]
you could wear red tights no one can see
them
[Music]
and i should have
little red booties
i prefer these ones
those are these will be like a
a peasant twitch
okay
[Music]
yeah i i'm only playing this now because
i keep picking up animal crossing and
then putting it back down again and
it can be very addicting
so this is the room i don't think you
saw much of last time it was like my
forest study
and now i'm kind of kidding it out a
little bit
[Music]
we've got to get to the shop before 10
so i've got to do my rounds
um but yeah i'm slowly
thinking
[Music]
[Music]
there's like a little table thing
this is where i cut my pumpkins yeah
pumpkins
chop chop chop chop
carbon pumpkin
this is where i
grew my potions
and this is actually based on
a guy what's his name crap
there's a guy who was in the occult he's
like extremely well known in the occult
and he lives in a house
near uh well right next to the loch ness
and some people say the loch ness is due
to his occultism
uh like it was like a demon that he
raised
which is pretty interesting so i thought
i'd do the same thing so
we have our spooky spooky woods with a
bloody lantern
[Applause]
[Music]
alistair crowley yeah i think that was
it
so i watched um
i watched a film which i always can't
remember
that was based around it this is my man
he hides behind the screen
and there's a spider-man
[Music]
and it was based all
around his experiences in the house
because he was basically trying to raise
demons
to control them and then to um bring
himself to a stage of enlightenment so
he could talk to his guardian angel
something like that so
he was trying to do something good in
the end by raising
oh
i'll turn down the game a bit more for
you guys
let me know how that sounds
oh ratchet incline that get brings you
back
every single day
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
also i must apologize if i'm a little
bit low beat today
it's um
it might be tmi but it's my first day of
the month and it's been extremely hard
months this month
very pink
and i just get really tired usually on
the first day
[Music]
that's why i just want to chill out and
just play animals
[Music]
maybe some of you
if you haven't seen this in a while and
i get to use the capture card
[Music]
i got really scared because i thought
that i didn't have
an extra hdmi
in the pc
but i do i have just enough
[Music]
okay so up here is where i'm going to
put my zen garden because i put it i'll
show you where i've put it so far i need
to get rid of this dude
maybe i'll eat my apples
i'll get rid of this tree
don't drop them eat them
there's little things like this that are
the reason why so many people stop
playing animal first things like can i
not just eat all of the apples but i'd
have to eat one apple at a time and you
would have thought that they would have
they wouldn't fix this stuff
if they wanted to so they obviously
don't want to because there is a time
sling and that means that you spend more
time
[Music]
just like social media
[Music]
[Music]
okay great well do i really want to pick
these up now
maybe i'll put them up when i do my zen
garden
okay let's
let's drop just drop this for now
because we're gonna end up just moving
all of this over there later okay bye
oh and so over here can i even get over
there there's some stuff here
what i want to do
is have you know how people do
illusions and it makes it like there's
like a tiny town and you're on this
gigantic mountain i want to do that down
here
but i need i need to get like tiny cars
and tiny houses and stuff so
i don't know how people make their
island so good and they have so much
stuff
yeah if you didn't know
uh this capture card made me buy
a view
lot in of uh
so you can say thank you to everyone
and i do have a ps2 so i've been wanting
to use it on that as well
just need to figure out what ps2 game i
want to play
[Music]
it's lagging a little bit though
[Music]
this is my
okay
[Music]
[Music]
almost as adorable as in game yeah
she is she is pretty damn cute
right i had this spooky music in my
spooky forest and they all sing the
spooky music even though there's other
music on the island but they all maybe
they just know it's spooky music and
they know it's spooky season but
listen to them
sorry
no i wanted to talk to you
[Applause]
so we're looking for
any halloween
things uh wooden blob table
i don't want that
i can hear something
[Music]
there it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna slowly make the whole entire
island
actually
[Music]
give me five
[Music]
[Music]
okay am i doing now right i bought
some stuff for here
so this is supposed to be an extension
of the playground i'm not quite sure how
i'm gonna make it work yet but we're
gonna make it work somehow i need some
sort of like archway
um
but yeah so we can put
these here hopefully
uh
[Music]
drinks machine to go with this snack
machine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh okay so now we just need to keep
finding
trying to find the bottles
and then quickly run to the shop
[Music]
you know what
i know like i said i sometimes play
animal crossing and i mess up again
but whenever i do play it's kind of just
a nice thing to do every day to unwind i
think that's why i haven't gotten very
far in my
oh yeah look i i changed for the
swimming pool i put it down here
um yeah i think that's why i don't get
very far in my designs because i just
play it usually for about an hour a day
or less than that really
and then i move on and it's just like a
nice little way to usually unwind after
work i have a little fishing pond now a
little
fishing fun
[Music]
and i want to put a fence all around
here into my secret garden
[Music]
where's godzilla yeah
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh is anyone making things because
sometimes they like
[Music]
make little diys
and they might be a halloween theme
i like this guy
this is a very important question bread
bowl or monster pick your poison
i actually i don't think i've ever tried
monster and i hate ready
i gave him a drinks machine he put it
here i can't see it when i walk in but
that's so cool because his room is like
a little office so i gave him a drinks
machine
[Music]
any fossils
okay
[Music]
we're just gonna go oh yesterday
i got my last bottle for the aquarium as
well
exciting day oh i also started to play
animal crossing again because it's
having a major update
and
the word on the street is
that um the cafe is coming back so if
anyone played any of the original
animals
[Music]
they've also made it much easier to run
away from the beast which i very very
much enjoy these smooth like impossible
to run away from bees
um
but
uh oh hello when did you get here
all right
where are you gonna laugh there
um
what was it saying
oh yeah in in animal crossing games um
kkk slider used to come in the little
cafe which its name escapes me now
um
but yeah you used to come to the cafe
every saturday or friday something like
that
and it was really cute because you could
have coffee
and then sit down and listen to kkk
and then when this game came out and you
just come
i think everyone was a little bit
disappointed including me
so it's really cool to
see that it might be coming back and i
think it's coming back as part of the
music it's going to be a
room inside the museum that is a cafe
so yeah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i found all the dinosaurs
i'm thinking like also did they have
randomized oh sorry i just i just hit
the microphone could they have
randomized the speech a little bit more
as well
[Music]
i was looking forward to buying
something new although that hammock
though that is cool
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i didn't come on early enough to go into
the shop
for my clothes the clothes shop
is that it
oh i can sell that guy my
wheeze
[Music]
yes
i'm rich
[Music]
spooky
spooky halloween man i don't really know
what's gonna happen on halloween which
is really good at having that with me
but i know a spooky halloween
because he sent me a letter at the
beginning of october and said he was
coming and that he wanted sweets
so now i buy sweets
hey luis luis luis lui
one of those
hey michael cafe
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah i need to feel my weight
[Music]
[Music]
take my weave
[Music]
no that's good
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
i can put that in the hole
hmm
[Music]
i do like the blue orange one
what are you talking about michael
it's appropriately festive the one with
the skeleton
i think it's the festive of dead i
imagine
crazy mango
oh are you still talking about red bull
and monster
i thought you'd talk about a character
[Music]
he
it how cute
i also got this hamster he was one of my
stars
see
bye bill
okay
[Music]
can i customize that how much
[Music]
me
maybe i can find a nicer pattern
[Music]
they're all for like
signs and stuff like you put blood on it
put nessie on it
[Music]
i can put i want to believe in aliens on
it
[Music]
should we just make a simple one
colorful
pattern
so many options tartan
[Music]
hey gaming with malachi
welcome to a super chill stream
i'll show you some of my spooky things
in a second
thank you for the super chat
you made my lights go crazy i don't know
if you can see them that well but they
did go crazy i promise you
[Music]
oh it's so late always so late
[Music]
flowers nah pizzas
[Music]
holy girls
[Music]
okay i'm thinking let's just go simple
plain and simple let's just
actually now i kind of like this let's
just keep it like this
[Music]
two green ones
two orange ones oh this is where i got
my pumpkins by the way
malakai
we're gonna try and make a
[Music]
spooky
[Music]
oh it's really sad and places sad spooky
like
oh
it's like
it's hanging
that's sad
uh
yeah oh no
wait
i need
one more pumpkin
one more orange
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please
okay fine i'll just have to water my
pumpkins
it's so cozy
it can be like very repetitive and
it's
very long so
you can't skip
talking and
oh my god
the um us isn't great like you can't
buy things in bulk or do things in bulk
really and you can't
stack in your inventory
much you can some things and everything
and not
things like flowers but you really
probably should be able to do that
um but it is definitely a chill game and
i think part of the reason why the
developers don't want to allow you to do
all those things that i just said is to
keep the pace very slow
which
i'm guessing is partly to do with the
vibe but also partly to do with how long
people spend playing the game
so monetary i guess
um
[Music]
what do i have here i want to
kettle piano bench floor lamp oh yeah
what does this look like
[Music]
oh there
little things like this as well
i wish it could be like the sims and you
could just go top down
uh you can do it inside the house
but when you're decorating the island it
can be a bit of a ball like right
[Music]
and then we'll be done and then i'll
show you what i've been working on
no i've never played ghost of sashima
and also fitting that i've been getting
this assortment [ __ ] this year it's
making it way more enjoyable that's
awesome i know i love stories like so
i'll see you the other day because james
has definitely inspired me to do things
in my real life
and uh i think we need to focus more on
that people are always like
um games are making kids stay indoors
and all these things and sure they do
have a negative impact but they also can
inspire you to better yourself in the
real world
expand your imagination and all that
kind of stuff what so i already have a
song
[Music]
yeah the music in that room with the
in my little study i thought my study
room like study forest room
it's very nice
it is nice
okay let's see the helmet
[Music]
put it here
[Music]
[Music]
this as well you don't know what they
are you just know their leaves here
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
yep
one non-functional replica of the
witcher 3 silver sword the one from
promotional and into screen
that's so cool
[Music]
wait see your
what's this i have three blades now just
got on the last one last month
that's so cool
[Music]
i haven't played it in a while actually
i was looking at my i've got a sticker
on my pc today and i was like
what can i find another one
[Music]
i definitely would have because i'm
still playing that uh the main
the big last dlc and it's so pretty i
just literally every time i play i just
can't get over how pretty it is
especially
considering how long it's been out for i
can't believe how pretty it still is
[Music]
should i sell this
yeah
[Music]
okay
bye oh that was nice
okay
[Music]
see you later alligator
okay
so
what we are going to do now
is
if i can close this one
i'm going to be showing you what i've
been attempting to work on in my spare
time um
i don't know how many of you know but
i'm making another
[Music]
music video in a game engine
and i thought i should probably show you
uh yeah as always very intimidating but
but i should probably show you because
it's interesting and
i'm quite liking the direction that it's
going so i want i want you to
have a little look
before i end the stream this is going to
be a shorter stream as well by the way
um but i'll just get it up i'm working
um still working in unreal engine 4. i'm
not going to move on to
5 until
i
need to make like a realistic
environment because
unreal engine 5
allows for crazy amounts of triangles
which means that you can have
very detailed meshes and environments uh
you can make great looking stuff and not
have to worry as much about the
performance which is brilliant
especially for someone like me who
does not model and therefore does not
model efficiently if she ever even does
um but i'm still on ue4 at the moment
because it's what i know it's what a lot
of my plugins are in and
i wanted to keep this simple
oh hey jamie
so yeah jamie and i have got the song
ready for this video so now it's just
riding on me and i'm probably gonna get
it done like by next month i think
because it's not it's not anything
spooky or scary
so it doesn't really make sense to
release it this month anyway
um it's actually very much the opposite
just spooky it's scary it's
it's very nice and chill
so
okay
let me
show you this
[Music]
huge ass
the song is complete that's later right
uh what what do you mean
the song is complete though yes
okay so
interesting um
this is
a little environment
it is modeled by
the very talented brayden
if you didn't know him already some of
you might know him as
onion knight or onion boy
um onion man perhaps
onion king some might even say but
anyway
i
i have been having some troubles with um
textures uh because it's not
unwrapped
but i think it's fine because this is
just gonna be for
a music video and therefore i don't have
to bake lights
um
full performance which is good uh
and yeah but i think it's it's a really
cute little environment to play around
with and basically what i'm doing now is
i've i've set up the environment and
then i created all the materials so
these are all the materials that i
created
and
i can show you
i i'll get it up here
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get up my messy
um documentation
that is a i what would you call it like
design
stuff um
[Music]
direction direction i don't know or
something like that
guillotine
oh
shouldn't say this
but
so
there's this
so this was kind of like the feel that i
was going for with the 3d model
uh i think brayden killed it
it's awesome it's great and then these
were the
vive so when i got them um it was all
uh
basic material so i remade them and i
wanted to follow like a kind of a lo-fi
color palette
so i went kind of for these like more
past silly colors very chill very calm
very relaxing
uh i love i love this green so that's
why i have made the walls this green
but then i i like the idea of having
some pops of color in there as well uh i
was watching a playthrough of hades and
i noticed they have little pops of like
really bright vivid colors
and it works very well in hades it looks
really really nice
so that's what i have tried to do here
um
i
i wonder if i can just turn off
so there's a skylight here
because i because i'm in the middle of
all of my uh
lighting
this wasn't how it looked initially
initially it was super super bright
and i haven't finished it properly yet
so if i turn that off it's quite dark
and i can make it lighter as well
[Music]
yes it's on two so i can like boost it
oh
oh that's not good
let's go to my skylight
so
because it's quite a small area you can
probably notice there's a lot of like
dark shadows and stuff
but that's okay because i'm putting in
loads of
lights point lights spotlights and stuff
like that
because i want it to kind of be
not daytime but like the morning time or
the evening time not quite sure what yet
but one of those dawn dusk one of those
moments
going on i think will be quite nice
um so i've got the skylight has a bit of
pink in it because that is the color
profile
uh sorry i haven't even been looking at
the comments i've just been like
rambling on has anyone said anything
art direction
yes
uh
jari i have i made a game a while ago
called perfection i'll put it in the
chat if you want to play it
um but honestly i haven't had the time
to make a game since university which is
it's like i guess sad but it's
it's a lot of commitment to do
especially when you have a full-time job
it's something i think about a lot
because i think i'd have to quit like
doing streams and youtube videos and
stuff but
here's
uh
and all my other things like writing and
singing um
here's my game lol it's free
um
yeah making someone else's game
yes i i work as a technical game
designer um associate but fingers
crossed promotion soon which would be
nice
um so yeah i
i do this as a job but we're not not
this i i do technical pipelines as a job
um that's kind of what i do in my day to
day
but it's cool i like i actually have a
lot of fun just setting up the
environments that's why i'm quite
enjoying doing these um music videos in
anvil engine because i feel like even
though i'd love to make a game it's kind
of like
a nice
um
thing to do instead because it means
like i get to keep on singing and you
know working on the next ep with jamie
but also working on
my own skills as a game developer
outside of my job as well because i
don't get to do stuff like this in my
job which is cool
um and who knows where it might take me
in the future
uh but yeah so what i did for my
technical setup of this i guess is i've
got
loads of different materials but they're
all instances of a base type of material
so you have
your basic
basic material and then uh
you'll have your
um what this
is called scalar yeah scalar parameters
um for metallic specular and roughness
and then this means that you can make um
do
do do do do do do material instances of
them and then whenever you do that so
this is the new material instance you
can open it up and then
you have all of these scalar parameters
that i set up and you can make it
different um
so this just it's always a really good
way it's always good to start like this
so that if you have anything that you
need to change to i don't know of the
quality of all of your materials you can
just do it to your base material and
then it'll update all of your instances
this is the kind of stuff that i do in
work to be honest just think about where
it flows
um
and then i've got a glass
instance
i don't make materials in rack though so
this isn't you know this isn't what i do
so i'm learning a lot to be honest um
it's good that i'm doing a low poly
style though because i think that's all
i i could do
but i'm quite i'm quite enjoying it i
tried to use uh quick saw for this but
again the texture map so these none of
this was unwrapped and if i put any um
any textures on it you can see all the
seams and it just doesn't look
it doesn't look very nice so i thought
you know what i'm actually quite happy
about that because this means that i
really do have to stick with my
limitation of it being
low poly
textures because i literally can't do
anything with these models that would be
really um
what's the word
complicated
so yeah but i
i spent probably too long on this color
scheme and i'm
quite happy with it i think it looks
really pretty um
so here's the phone i got i did try out
because i was having fun with the the oh
no see it's just too much isn't it i put
a uh
uh quixo material
on just on this little button bit here
and it's got little fingerprints all
over it but it kind of looks too much
now i'm not sure if i like that or not
i don't know
brass fingerprint material see this is
the material
it's really cool because it's got it's
got the fingerprints all over it but i
just think it looks a bit too much
we can
have a little look where is it
brass instance
let's find the fingerprint material
oh that's because i multiplied it
let's try this how does this look
sorry i was just updating my twitch
information
no so i haven't tried unreal engine 5
yet kaiser i'm gonna do that whenever i
need to make a realistic
game because of
because of the
awesome amount of triangles that it can
handle which is great for someone like
me who is not a modeler and
does not know how to make performant
models
so i'm very excited to try that out when
i can
but yeah this is just keeping things
simple in ue4
so i've got uh this is actually
my skylight is doing this
light on the floor but then i have got
an extra spot like here and then i have
used here which i was extremely excited
about
um a
light function material which is like an
animated material on the light and it
kind of looks like cars are passing by
so i'm hoping that i can go in there and
mess around with that and have it kind
of stop and start so that it's a bit
more randomized on when the material
plays but we'll see what i'm able to do
with that
[Music]
my idea is i need to get a light in here
and what i want to do i've got some
pages to go into these books from my
actual diaries and stuff like that so
i'm going to update that and update
what's on the screen
and
on the phone
and i've got these textures
uh oh that's just a plain uh where's the
uh yeah so i've got these polaroids that
i'm gonna
turn into
uh
well polaroids
and what i was hoping to do was to
record myself on a green screen and get
myself in here but now that i'm looking
in i think it's gonna look
pretty crap to be honest
so instead i'm hoping i can get myself
projected in different parts of the room
so i'm thinking
i can maybe
have myself
in this book
and i'm going to get loads of different
cameras and have them set up to be
looking at different parts of the room
so i can have me in the book and then i
can use post-processing to put on
a
special
overlay of me to make it look like i'm
more lining or something you know like
i'm
a sketch or something
and then have me on the phone which
could be quite cool
uh
maybe had me in
a
polaroid maybe not i don't think it
would work uh on the laptop
but yeah
we shall see and then i'm quite i'm
quite proud of this so this is i i need
to finish it but this is outside
and i think it looks really cool through
the window because of the glass
kind of made this like frosted glass
material and i just think it looks so
cool with the neon signs and stuff but
yeah i just need to
uh to finish all of this
and get them all going out
and then hopefully
they'll look really good
but yeah
and i left it off last time i was
just putting in
the lights i think it's gonna take me a
little while
but
i don't know i'm just
having fun with it it's quite
a chill thing to do just lighting an
environment
quite like it because you go here and
then you go okay
what kind of light would i like
using wall boomerang
maybe i'll do wall inverted v
oh no that's way too much maybe not
maybe we
do something a bit lighter what about
spread out what's that
that looks better
i can't really notice that's good
i'm going to do one of these for each of
these lights
it's gonna be so or maybe i'll just do
one for every few of the lights um yeah
maybe that's a better idea
just see how it looks
and then i did make a quick blueprint
the other day
um for
yeah i made this candle blueprint
and
it's got here
inside the blueprint it's got a point
light and a spotlight and if you
have used point like tick that uses a
point light but then you can
untick it and it uses a spotlight
um
and then when you play
it should i haven't even tested it
yeah so it's the maximum intensity is is
changing
at uh
well it's a timeline that i've made but
i definitely need to go in and
fix it up a bit but i think
that's quite effective we just need to
change the max and min because that is a
mental
metal
i need to get rid of this mirror
yeah that's not so bad
and i can use that on different parts i
also want to need to put in the
particles in this scene as well so
there's still a lot still a lot that i
need to do i wasn't sure if i should
show you today because i don't know i
feel like it's slow progress but i'm
also quite proud of it at the same time
so why not show you
spotlight we don't really want a
spotlight oh that's that's gonna be
crazy isn't it
yeah i don't want that one
i love inserting myself into art too
kind of looks like the outside kind of
looks like a mix between sun hill and
bioshock interesting yeah i've seen why
you said sun hill because of the the fog
so i was watching a tutorial a lighting
tutorial the other day and um they said
to always put fog in your seam because
the light picks it up and like bounces
through the fog and then i did it and i
was like damn that looks good like let
me show you um
okay so this is the fog
and fog density is it was a [ __ ] height
fall off
maybe fog density
yeah i guess it would be
okay so that's zero and that's one
i don't know that's 3.5 so say if we put
like 20 fog density in here
it will only go up to 10 apparently
so look at my room now
and look at it now
okay that's that's gross i thought it
was on one before
point five
point one
even point one just makes a lot of
difference i think
just gives it a bit more atmosphere
especially outside
maybe a bit less
this is why i take so long
spend ages
i thought i made the clouds a bit
denser
oh no don't want that
i guess they just kind of blend in
so i made the sky
the same colors as
this i tried to
try to release
it doesn't really have the orange
i can't really see it
it's more subtle
anyway let's get back to these
see i've used one of these on the phone
as well
the phone's an emissive
material but then it's one of this on
the phone and it looks like it's
spreading out from the phone
and fun fact a lot of this stuff is
actually what i've got
in the flat
so this is my sippy cup
here and it's it's on
it's on this
and my old laptop that i used to have
before i started uh
streaming i should probably get this in
a mess of color
sorry a massive um
material
[Music]
[Music]
what material do you have
phone glass what are you
oh
don't look at this it's really messy
it's pretty messy don't look at it
um
uh what color
wait
is anyone in the chat gonna come to the
halloween stream do you think maybe
maybe
is it purple it's like a dark purple but
we'll see or maybe i could do blue
let's have a look
oh no sorry 1-1
oh
oh screen
i don't know if i like that color
what color do i want the screen
hmm
be purple
i don't know
maybe
maybe not
maybe pink
the switch is green
maybe pink hmm
we'll see
leave out that for now
sweet
hey lydia yeah i'm really looking
forward to the halloween stream it
should be good
i've uh i've got
uh
i've got an outfit well part kind of an
outfit on the way it's not really
but i've got something on the way to
wear which i'm very excited
uh and then we're going to play
fair frame
and some
games with friends i've got um back for
blood downloaded so we can play that
that'll be fun
uh i think we're gonna play plasmaphobia
as well
just cause
apparently it's had um
some updates
maybe a whiteflight don't know
just looks a bit dark
dark
gosh
i'm going to take forever just to
do these little things but right back
area
[Music]
this is what i mean about the uvs
okay
is that okay
that'd be fine we'll just leave that one
like that
okay
let's do another one
15
degrees
angle
oh interesting
of course we can't have both because
they'll overlap that's fine i wasn't too
sure about these ones anyway
let's remove you bye
they were like giving a little sparkly
sparkly
but uh yeah i'm not sure how i felt
about the sparkles
stephen does this light even do a thing
i don't i don't know
since it just it just puts a strip down
the wall
okay
if i just choose a few good ones that
work for these
then i can duplicate them of course
because it's spread out why do i use
that
stovepage
uh
maybe this could work
oops where did you go
hmm
it's not gonna connect right
connect
remember remember remember i remember
i was watching um
oh
what are they called what they called
hocus pocus
the other day
and it's it's not as good as i remember
but it's still it's still good fun i
used to love i used to love that film
when i was a kid
if i couldn't sleep it was the film that
me and my mum would watch until i could
finally fall asleep
which is very wholesome
but yeah i loved
loved that film
okay that's an interesting one
that works
interesting i like that one
okay
uh
john
why did you hide your videos of little
nightmares one
um
i don't know if i intentionally hid them
uh what i might have done
is it might have been
oh you know what i'm gonna
i think that was at the time when i
didn't want to have unedited videos on
my
channel
because i thought it was unprofessional
and would damage my channel or i don't
know
so they are probably unlisted or in like
a playlist
but i'm sure they're still there
uh i mean i can have a look
let me have let me have a little look
through my youtube
because a few times now i've had a kind
of like a
crazy
moment with my youtuber i'm like what am
i doing with it and then i just move
things make new playlists remove things
i don't know i'm going crazy
and the only people who get to see
everything is uh
my patreons because
they
i don't delete anything for them
but
i don't know
still nightmares come on is there not a
little nightmare
playlist
apparently i don't have any little
nightmares playing this
hmm
okay
here they are so they
are unlisted
let me have a look
are they in a playlist what playlist are
they in
live stream live night little nightmares
full playthrough i knew i had a playlist
like where is the playlist then
youtube why you be like
let me find
little nightmares
if i search it won't find it i know it
exists
i'll find it
little nightmares there it is
share
coffee okay okay i hope you're still
there because i have the playlist
here's a little nightmares
one full playthrough
playlist
it's all live
so
sorry there will be rambling but
it's there if you want to watch it
but you are right they were unlisted
because yeah i was i was um
embarrassed
by the fact that they weren't um edited
i thought they weren't good enough
but i'm slowly learning that i should
just leave things up for you because
some of you enjoy them and that's what
matters the most
okay i don't want to put too
many
on these things
i don't want to overdo it
a bowl oh that's quite cool
bowl
it's a ball
okay
now let's just spread them out
oh this is the stupid line one
starburst
starburst
cute
starburst
stylus
do you still look weird you just look
weird what's wrong with you
maybe i should not put a beam on this
one
there
maybe i'll put the starburst
on this one
i'm sorry if this is really boring
it's it's very quiet isn't it it's much
quieter than most of the other streams
but
there will be screens to come don't you
worry
i also am in talks with a really
talented artist about some
um emotes
which is extremely exciting i've been
thinking about getting emotes for so
long
and uh she's called sleepiest
on twitter and instagram sleepiest
designs or sleepiest
and she's really good and yeah i'm very
excited
it's gonna be like scared ones of me
screaming
and what other ones
the scared ones of me screaming there's
going to be one of me being brave so you
can tell me when i'm being brave because
i want you to do that
and uh
i asked
her maybe if there's a possibility we
can do one for balls
but i even i'm not quite sure how we're
going to do that one so
that might not happen
uh but yeah and then obviously a singing
one as well because we've we've gotta
have them we
wow this is a lot of lines
can i
maybe put on
this one
is that too much oh jesus that's way too
much
hmm interesting maybe if i
put the intensity down
it could look a bit nicer
maybe
maybe
yeah exactly mantas jenny does make
really good
good art
oh my god blown eardrums that's such a
good idea
that's such a good
idea i love that i love that so much
okay we i might have to change one of
them then
what do you think what what one should
we change um
me screaming me singing me
like being brave
or the balls
emote
which one should be changed to a blown
eardrum
i love that idea
i think that's hilarious
i don't know why i keep turning these i
can put them whatever way i would like
i figured we needed like a music one but
maybe we don't need a music one
or maybe we don't need the brave one
maybe i'm just like being too nice to
myself
because the blown eardrum one would be
hilarious to see
uh the screaming or blown at eardrum
both have the same effect
oh yes that oh yeah that's true that's
true ah
that's so true
so
you would want either the scream
or all the blue and eardrums is that
what you're saying
interesting interesting i mean there's
no reason why we can't obviously ask
more in the future either
i say we i mean me
add some purple lights with the pink
what like
these lights
we could always try
let's have a look
i have my light my light palette here oh
my
my color palette but as soon as i
i've got to put it on my other screen
because as soon as i go to click it'll
it'll leave again
but yeah i can i can do some purple
let's try
is that too dark yeah it probably would
be
this one
what do you think of that
it's quite nice actually good shout out
we can make some of them purple and some
of them some of them pink yeah it's a
good idea
thank you very much
michael
i'll do that i'll do that later
let's just get this figure figured out
for now this will be my one task and
then i'll stop that'll stop
stop the stream because
you would have seen you would have seen
that was my main goal for you to see and
just have a little
little glimpse into what i'm trying to
make on the side at the moment
i'm trying to make this kind of like
what i do
makes sense in a way it's it's so
difficult because i do so many different
things
and i just want to
find something that makes sense does
that make sense
does that make sense when i find
something that makes sense in my sense
do i make sense do you make sense
nothing makes sense
but yeah i just want to make something
that encompasses everything i suppose
but that is also
feasible to do in the amount of free
time that i get
uh
i think this is like the the best thing
but even these take so long and it's
it's so difficult i mean
i'm not gonna lie i was actually
thinking the other day of like should i
do a masters
because it's crazy like i have a job and
everything
but
i really just miss
making things and honing my craft and
when i went to uni i went to uni to do
like mixed media arts
using game engines
but i wanted to do like installations
and and
interactive pieces that were more like
art than like
your
typical video game
uh
and
i never got to do that
and it's a real shame
because i was very much excited to do
that
but i don't know it's it's it's a tough
one
because you know i do i do like my job
but at the same time it's
it's not very like creative it's very
technical which is good because it's
teaching me so much and it's really nice
to have technical skills
especially
to fall back on you know
don't have to worry as much about job
security if you have technical skills
but i miss all the creatively fun stuff
that's why it's nice to have some
something on the side to work towards
yeah you might be right there mantas
ah it matters yeah man i wish i wish i
knew someone
business-minded or i wish i was
business-minded
it blows my mind how people have people
do like set of their own businesses and
studios and stuff
it's so cool but also at the same time
absolutely bloody terrifying and
you know i just think i guess
the first step is to come up with a
feasible idea of the things that you
would make or even if it's just a game
like what
what is your
vertical slice i suppose um to then go
to publishers and ask for money and
stuff
yeah i agree sidnator
oh man i wish i wish that were possible
just yeah just take a year out
see what happens i mean i understand why
it's not though
because you can't just take a year out
and be like i'm gonna try this thing and
then it doesn't work out and you're like
hey i'm back hey i'm back
and they're like where have you been
chime and trying a different thing and
it didn't work out so now i'm back
take me back
although why not i mean if they need you
why not i guess
i don't know i don't know i don't know
corporate life
hmm do i want this here because the
polaroid
movie there
okay
now
if we get this
color
and we put it on some of these
i mean we could go
no
every odd one
um
hey sam [ __ ] man
what a funny name
sorry i didn't mean to make fun of your
name um
i i'm actually not making a game i'm
making like a
cinematic i guess it's it's a music
video
i made an anvil engine
so it's a very small uh environment
and i'm gonna be using green screen to
put myself in it i'm just doing the
lights now and i need to finish off the
outside of it
uh but yeah it's just gonna be a little
three-minute cinematic
uh for a song that uh me and producer
jamie at horizon productions have made
so
yeah it's gonna be cute
hopefully it's gonna be
kind of like life uh li-fi lo-fi vibes
although the song isn't low five but
i want the song well the song is very
cozy and
chill
so i wanted the video to reflect that
and these are definitely chill vibes so
i'm liking it
let's move this one over
okay
how does that look
hmm
not sure about these ones
but i think overall
it does look kind of like ferro lights
doesn't it
because they do bounce off the walls
like that
maybe just went a bit overkill on some
of them
but
yeah not so bad
but it's not green eyes flips table
ah we can't risk it i don't want to get
in trouble by the spotify people or the
music industry people
ah
[Music]
i don't know
i think the song sounds good if you
think it would benefit from that though
jamie like
try it let's see how it sounds but i'm
quite happy with where the song is at
the moment
so yeah that's what i'm going to be
doing
i'm i'm gonna be hopefully finishing the
lights
by
this weekend
hopefully
and
then i can
well i'm gonna be recording myself this
weekend as well
and then i can put myself into the scene
but yeah this is where i'm at so far i'm
quite happy with my color palette i need
to get rid of that bloody mirror um need
to finish the outdoors as well but that
that should be easy because it's just a
matter of copying and pasting the
buildings really and just getting them
to go down here
um
but yeah i'm quite i'm quite proud of it
quite excited to share it it should be a
nice chill happy cozy little oh yeah
there's a duck which is uh
a little easter egg a little yeah a
little easter egg i guess
for those of you who know you know
anyway
that is probably all i'm going to show
you because i don't want to bully too
much with me just changing shades and
stuff all the time
so yeah i hope you enjoyed watching
i know it's okay it's more of an inside
joke to myself
okay okay fair enough fair enough
a peek into the mind of the yagman do a
model of a dwarf star
hello paehon sorry but i'm leaving now
i'll awake next week i can dig that
got some nice metal tunes in that game
oh yeah because you put some in the
discord didn't you oh yeah let me put
the discord in the chat for anyone who
wants to get involved in the discord who
isn't already in the discord
there you go
so you can join the discord if you'd
like to
um that's where i'll keep you up to date
on everything coming out all the live
streams i live stream every thursday at
8 30 p.m
bst
uh next week we're going to be starting
on alan wake we're supposed to play that
today but we didn't i couldn't bothered
so uh we'll play that next week and then
on
saturday the 30th we have a charity
halloween stream i'm pretty excited for
it so that's at 3 pm until about 10 11
ish so yeah i really hope that some of
you can make it
but
either way
i will see you
next week
so thank you for spending the evening
with me
looking at my animal crossing town
looking at my
current personal project
and uh
i'll see you next week i'm going to say
goodbye to who i can see in the chat so
goodbye sednata goodbye kieran white
goodbye
mantas goodbye rexolite
goodbye
f196
um
goodbye jamie charity halloween bonanza
goodbye michael castilla spencer sweet
spending time with you again oh that's
really cute
um
goodbye rick's alike goodbye
kieran i'm saying goodbye to everyone
again all right goodbye pay han
uh goodbye m196 goodbye i'm just saying
goodbye to everyone again now i'm right
okay i'm gonna leave i'm gonna leave
okay thank you again i'll see you next
week uh have a lovely day or evening
have a great weekend too okay
bye
bye john